Welcome to the famous - and infamous -
Las Colinas Resort.
Acapulco in 1980 was the best place to be.
Everyone from Hollywood was there,
and the parties were insane.
The aesthetic was really unique
and wonderful.
You guys know the word "bodacious"?
The hotel is a complete extension
of Acapulco.
We needed something
with a lot of personality
that screams and shouts
"Mexico" in every shot.
Here we are in the lobby.
Most of what you're going to see
wasn't here.
The lattice work was created,
inspired by lattice work from Acapulco.
Those arches weren't there.
Of course, the color wasn't here.
When I got here, it was kind of like
a beigey brown color.
And within a day,
they had painted the entire hotel pink.
It definitely brought it more to life.
It just gave it a...
like a positive energy.
We went a little crazy,
and we said, like... "why not?"
It's very flashy, it's very vibrant,
very... 80s.
I hope coming to visit Las Colinas
will always be "in fashion."
See what I did there?
Yes, I'd want to go back to the 80s.
Are you crazy?
Who wouldn't want to go back to the 80s?
I love the 80s. I love the fashion
that happened in that time.
I like the fun about the 80s.
When you're wearing 80s clothes,
it just makes you feel...
I don't know, more badass.
It's a collaboration, with wardrobe,
with hair and make-up.
We have an amazing team.
All the art, all the lamps
and every detail that you can see,
was designed and custom-made
for the show.
Even though it's a comedy,
even though it's so bold and so colorful,
it's a very authentic and fun story.
The vibe, the food, the colors,
the people...
This is the real Mexico.
Acapulco is the real Mexico.